you
thanks everyone for coming I don't know
I lost track I lost track of what number
of meet up this is for the group but
it's been growing really nicely and
we're happy to be at spotify they have
an amazing space as you can see and it's
really good of them to host us our very
first speaker from the data engineering
group was a Spotify employee so in a
sense we're kind of coming back home
even though the first group wasn't here
but I always always point on Eric I love
to make fun of Eric Eric like started
this whole thing off so Eric's here cool
so we wanted to i'm going to introduce
josh from chart beat in a minute however
before i do that i wanted to tell you
that we're playing we're holding a
really interesting experiment tonight
i'm the founder of haka labs and i had
this crazy idea that we can beat hacker
news now we're haka hjk ka their hacker
we're labs their news.com actually they
don't have a hacker news com we r co so
this is our site H a kicking a lab schoo
for those of you haven't seen it and we
launched our very very minimally
horribly minimally Viable barely viable
comments feature this week it doesn't
look like much but we have a feeling
that we can engage a really high-end
high quality network of engineers so
tonight this is actually a blurb this is
a landing page in the site you'll find
it on the homepage for Josh's talk and
we'll be posting the video of the talk
there in the next couple days but here's
the thing if you want to ask josh a
question tonight you have to do it on
the site in our MVP comments feature
which means you're going to have to
OAuth in through github which means you
have to have github but get this all
this all should work on your mobile
device by the way I've done it and the
OAuth experience is not bad so we need
your feedback we need your help we want
to see your comments in the form of
questions on the site and when josh is
done I'm going to come up here and read
comments
off the site and those are going to be
the question so if you just play along
like I'd really I'd really love it I'll
be your friend forever yeah so that's
the site so you can check that out and
feel free to let us know what you think
so i'm going to introduce josh schwartz
who is a data scientist at heart beat
he's been there a couple years before
that he did some pretty interesting
stuff including MIT a stint in academia
coffee roasting in San Francisco and
then he decided to come back to the real
world and now he's a data engineer / a
scientist at chart beat so he has a
really interesting talk lined up I've
been looking forward to this for a long
long time so I hope that you'll give him
warm round of applause and your
undivided attention thanks Josh take it
away all right is this on hopefully all
right um well thanks very much for
having me i was going to open with
saying that you guys should feel free to
interrupt me i guess you should feel
free to interrupt me via github but uh
but anyway I'd love i love this to be as
interactive as possible so if people do
have questions through whatever medium
we should go through definitely jump in
let me go ahead and pull this up
alright um so the plan for today is to
talk through basically the entire kind
of data pipeline that we've built at
sharpie'd so we're going to talk through
start with the real time system that we
kind of was our first core piece of
infrastructure talk to you how that
works what sort of data is coming
through it move on to a historical
pipeline which we've bolted on over the
last couple of years and finally sort of
finish off with really neat application
of that pipeline which is basically some
work that some folks from my team have
done on generating human readable text
using this historical data store um
before I jump into that though you know
whenever I'm putting together a talk I
like to sort of try to figure out you
know why the hell would anybody actually
listen to this right um and and I think
maybe there are three things that I
might phrase as you know things you
might get out of this so so first of all
on we've built a pipeline which just
handles a lot of data so we handle at
you know at our most extreme Peaks
something like 250,000 plus requests per
second day to day we're handling over
200,000 request a second so it's just
it's just a pipeline which handles a lot
of data which might be interesting if
you're a person who's also building
stuff that handles a lot of data um
we've also built this data warehouse
over the last couple years and I'd say
that that it the building the warehouse
has not been easy and we've learned a
lot of lessons and we've learned them
the hard way and I think that hopefully
some things I have to say might save you
some time and building things in the
future um and and finally I there might
be some neat applications I think the
language stuff is pretty cool and and
one of the kind of central tenants of
what I have to say is that you know a
lot of the I'm not going to show you any
fancy math or really sophisticated
machine learning or anything like that
the point is that once you've got a good
pipeline in place that lets you sort of
do queries quickly it's often not that
hard at least in our experience to put
on really cool products on top of it so
so you know maybe you'll find find some
inspiration there um so with that said
let me jump in um so first of all for
those who don't know on char Pete is a
company that's been around for about
five and a half years we're based
entirely in
your core in Union Square we've got
around 70 employees and the split is
something like fifty percent engineering
and fifty percent you know business and
whatnot um and traditionally I the thing
that we were known for was real time
analytics on websites so the idea is we
talk about the state of a site in kind
of a second-by-second way so we think
about a site as sort of a state machine
where you know at any given moment you
can capture okay where are the people on
the site where who are the people where
do they come from where are they going
and all that um and this end ended up
becoming a really powerful tool for
people in the media industry um you know
the way that I tend to phrase this is it
you know if you think about an editor at
you know your favorite you know daily
newspaper right that person essentially
has an infinite supply of content and a
very finite number of places that they
can be promoting that content so you can
only post so many things to Twitter a
day you can only have so many things on
your homepage so on and so on and so you
kind of have have an infinite number of
decisions you could make at any given
second and you need some data to help to
support that decision-making apparatus
and we ended up filling in that role so
to show you an example of what a char
Pete dashboard that a person's using day
to day looks like it's something like
this so here I'm showing data from
gizmodo com who's nice enough to let us
damn other stuff um so what we see here
is that there are twenty thousand five
hundred and twenty people on gizmodo at
the second that I took the screenshot on
there are forty 171 people on the
homepage a thousand 49 on this article
and so on and so on 2414 people are
coming from email apps and I am and so
on right and so you can imagine that if
you're trying to figure out you know
what stories to promote let's say you
might notice something like wow this
story people are reading for twice as
long as most of my other stories but
it's not getting as much promotion as
other stories maybe I should you know
move that to a better place on my site
that's that's the sort of decision
making that that people are making um so
now let's let's get into the actual data
so how does it get into our system what
happens is a customer installs our
JavaScript on their site um and then the
the JavaScript
then on their customers in their
customers browsers it continually sends
us a stream of pings those pings come in
the form of image requests and then the
URL encodes the data on and so here I'm
screen capping in you know very official
form just screen cathing like you know
chrome inspect element on and what we
see is basically I don't know if you
guys can see but but all of these are
image requests that are going out while
I'm while I'm on a given page on gizmodo
on and this this may or may not be be
legible from where you are but but there
are a bunch of fields which encode data
about about my browsing session on the
page um I'll classify that data into
sort of 22 forms so first of all we've
got on what you might call page metadata
or user metadata that's telling us stuff
which is kind of static and it's about
just the instance of browsing that we're
looking at so you know we have a
parameter that encodes the host so it
says this person's on gizmodo com
there's the path which says in this case
says / because I had the home page of
gizmodo open um there's a unique user ID
which says okay this is this person and
it persists between pages and whatnot um
then we've got what i like to call
measurement data um so measurement data
is stuff that we're actually measuring
that maybe is more interesting right so
it's it's it's kind of recording data
about the state of the user so to throw
in a few examples of that on this you
know first parameter the sea parameter
is telling us that when i took this
screen cap i had had the page open for
14 minutes and you know 46 seconds the x
parameter is telling us that the top of
my screen was 208 pixels down from the
top of the page we can see the height of
the page all that probably the thing
that gets is most excited is is we have
a kind of fancy way of counting which i
won't get into here but where we sort of
count the amount of time that a person
spend actively I viewing the page so we
sort of continually pull a user to ask
whether they're actually we actually
think they're looking at the page and so
we we count that up over time and encode
that here so you see a good example in
this where i was spending a bunch of
time taking screencaps and so I had the
page open for 14 minutes I was engaged
with a page for only a total of four
ken's so there's a huge disparity that
were that were able to kind of kind of
tease apart so this data is coming in
and you know the thing to note is that
this data is coming in from each person
on each of our customer sites right so
let's get into you know what happens
from there so I'm going to start off by
talking about our real-time processing
pipeline which is what actually is
receiving those pings um so in designing
a real-time pipeline the first thing I
think about is you know kind of what are
the system requirements um so first of
all um you know anything that's going to
work for us is going to have to handle
an extraordinarily high right rate
because it's you know it's our customers
customers who are paying us so we saw
20,000 people on gizmodo there's one
site but they're in have 20,000 people
sending us pings and if you aggregate
across all of our customers that ends up
being hundreds of thousands of pings
that are coming in every second on the
other hand the read rate is much slower
because the read rate is sort of big o
of customers right so I you know the
people who are issuing reads are people
who are paying us you know editors at
gizmodo or people at char Pete or
whatever and so there's a much smaller
number of those so it's kind of an
interesting data data database in that
the right rate and the rebate have a
huge disparity on the other hand we
still want on the the response to reads
to be quite quick right so so a person
is looking at a dashboard they want the
data be to be updating constantly so so
even though there aren't a ton of raids
we need very low latency um and for
reasons that I'll get into a bit we want
to support completely arbitrary querying
so we want people to answer essentially
any question about the real time state
of their site which is a complicating
factor another note which makes life a
little bit easier is that queries are
always buy domain I'm so in that sense
it's kind of embarrassing Lee parallel
in terms of you know breaking things up
by domain I'm and that's because you
know if I'm an editor at gizmodo I can't
look at you know somebody else's
dashboard so the queries that I'm making
are just just for my domain um so with
that said let me go in and actually sort
of diagram out what our pipeline looks
like um so I you know that I think this
is probably a pretty standard kind of
diagram but what we have is is first of
all JavaScript on the client
cited sending pings all things are going
to a universal endpoint which sits
behind Amazon zlb so there's just pinga
sharpie'd net and all traffic comes in
whether it's coming from gizmodo or from
charpy com or from gawker com or whoever
it is um and and the elb basically
balances pings across a set of what we
call fronts which are machines that are
that are run running engine acts and
they're just providing a routing layer
on the purpose of the writing later
layer will become clear in a second
which is that um behind that is a layer
which we call memory fly memory fly is
kind of the first core piece of
infrastructure that we built and and
we'll talk about the details of it in a
second but you can think about it as for
the moment as an intermedia base which
is going to respond to the queries that
that that we need to do to power the
dashboard and the way that memory fly
works is it basically is shorted by
domain so you know all traffic for
gawker com goes to one instance of
memory fly all traffic for terp ecom
goes to another instance of memory fly
and engine ax handles the routing to
those so engine X just literally has a
lookup table that says okay this is a
ping it says it's coming from Wacha com
let me send it to memory fly one this is
a ping that says 4p com let me set it to
memory flight to UM pings go in there
and then on the other hand we have the
same sort of look up mapping that's
happening on on the read side so you
know if you're on at RP dashboard you're
hitting a generic set of API servers and
the API servers then you know look up
the request and say okay this is a
request for data for Walker let me you
know go to the memory fly which serves
gawker data and and and I asked her my
answer on so to talk about memory fly if
you know if that's like the secret sauce
in the system for a second um memory fly
I is is something that we built in-house
it's been around for a number of years
and has predecessors with some stuff we
did with with folks at bit ly um but the
key thing that it does is it's an
in-memory data store and kind of in its
simple simplest form what you can think
about it being is just a thing that
keeps track of a linked list of active
sessions right so if you imagine you
know if each one of those pings if we
kept track
who we thought was on the page and we
had that link list you could run the
list and compute anything you wanted so
for example if you wanted to know you
know how many people are there from
facebook on my homepage you just run the
list of all people who are on any page
on your site you figure out how many
people are on the homepage who are also
from Facebook you sum up the number you
report it back right um that of course
would be a terrible way to actually
design something since it would be
incredibly expensive every time right um
so so what we actually do is is a pre
aggregate the information which we know
is going to be asked for all the time so
what happens is as a ping comes into our
system it puts itself in the list but it
also increments the counts that need to
be on need to be incremented so for
example we you know for keeping track of
the number of people who are on the
homepage a ping comes in that says it's
from the home page it increments a
counter that says it's on the home page
on then you know because we're getting a
sequence of pings wallet person is
staying on the page what happens is when
subsequent things come in they sort of
look themself up they realize i'm
already in the linked list they update
the information they need to update and
they don't increment the counters that
they don't need to increment on each
ping sits inside of the list and sits
with kind of its own timer which says
okay after this timer goes off I won't
be considered to be on the page anymore
right and so that's how we manage kind
of active keeping track of active
sessions so I come in and I say okay you
should expect to hear from me in the
next 30 seconds a ping comes in with
with with that noted in the ping and
then if we don't hear from you in the
next 30 seconds we say well this person
must have left we didn't receive the
message and then the ping deletes itself
from the linked list and also decrements
all the counters that it needs to
decrement and so is it so it's kind of
this you know each pane kind of manages
the state of every counter that it that
it's engaged with um now of course there
we can't precompute every possible thing
that a person might want and and so well
what we have is basically a system where
lua is embedded in inside of the
database so a person can submit an
arbitrary Luis script which can run the
list of pings and do it
ever at wants um and so that's how
that's how we're able to kind of you
know if you're going to let's say
rapidly prototype you know figure out
what interesting data to pull might be
you can implement the script in lua um
try it out try it out a few times and
then you know if you decide that it's
something that you actually do want to
keep around all the time go back to the
C code that's that's the you know the
native thing that it's written in and
add the pre aggregation for it for that
sort of counts oh that's how how we kind
of I you know for lack of a better word
multiplex a thing to allow for a kind of
ad hoc analysis and 44 you know
production traffic on as a quick note
you know one thing that you might have
wondered when I had the initial diagram
op is okay so you're putting all traffic
for gawker com on one server what
happens when you get a site that has too
much traffic for one server no matter
how big it is the answer is that that we
shard amongst servers so this was used
for only the very largest sites in the
internet basically um but but what
happens is we we essentially you know
spin up k servers where K is probably
somewhere between you know two and
twenty and each one is going to handle
you know one over K fraction of the
traffic and what happens is when a ping
comes in we hash its user ID so all
traffic for a given user on that host
goes to a consistent shard so let's say
you know all whatever a through f users
go to this first server all you know
whatever the g through ours go here and
all us through csgo here on and so now
each memory flight is keeping track of a
subset of data and then what happens is
we have to have a separate layer which
basically is kind of a MapReduce layer
so when an API request comes in instead
of simply hitting a single memory fly
that that request hits this layer which
we call a combiner layer the combiner
layer kind of forms out the request to
all the memory flies that are that it
needs to ask questions of and then you
know reduces the the results back to a
single response and senses back to the
API there um and with that like I said
we've
enable the scale to you know for a given
site being able to handle you know well
over a million concurrent people on the
site which is quite a lot to have Anna
linked list to give you a you know a few
fancy stats about how cool we r memory
fly these days handles like I said at
the beginning every day is hitting over
200 thousand requests a second many days
is peaking much higher than that on
every day it's tracking more than 9
million people on a site at once or
sorry you know aggregator across all of
our sites is cutting more than 9 million
people and in total the data ingress is
something like a petabyte a month so it
handles quite a bit of data any answers
questions quite quickly um with that I
think uh and actually as a quick you
know sort of demo of what it does and
this might be illegible here but uh but
the idea is okay let's actually see I
memory fly pivoting and you know on the
fly so here if you can see it at all
we've selected okay I only want to look
at traffic from facebook and all of the
counts on the site are adjusted so
whereas the top number was twenty
thousand people on the site before now
it says 1236 that's a number of people
on the site who are just from facebook
and every number has adjusted to keep to
keep a track of that that's all
happening via you know both a little bit
of lua and and the sort of pre are
heated see counts on so with that that
sort of that the end of the real-time
portion I thought I might stop for a
second and see if anybody had any
questions that were then we're burning
before we move on we do have a great
question so I there's there's a kind of
complicated system where memory fly does
its best effort to dump data so it so if
if memory fly can it writes all that
stayed out to disk and then basically
what it does is it can replay on the the
pings back through itself so it needs to
get back in a consistent say so the
second that it comes back up the first
thing that it does when it comes alive
is it looks and sees if there's a dump
and if so it loads them um it's not
perfect and an interesting artifact of
building a real-time system which we'll
get into a little bit in a bit is that
you know the sort of nice thing about
being
building a real-time system is well the
numbers will be different in a minute
anyway so you know it doesn't have to be
that robust and you know then when you
want to build a historical system on top
you wish that people hadn't made those
decisions a few years ago um not great
so since we're gonna try to make this as
family as possible a couple you jumped
in online someone commented that it
looks like a consistent hash and they
set react like a react of dynamo lineage
what happens when the ring grows or
shrinks huh great question um really
good question so they're kind of on to
two things that happen depending on the
site and you know this might be overly
detailed or it might be just right
depending on your level of interest in
our stuff but I so so we have two
concepts one is what we call the general
ping pool and one is is what we call
specialized ping servers so for the
largest sites we actually need to kind
of make sure that their load balanced
incorrect ways and so that means that we
have specialized servers and people have
said I want Gawker on this server and
it's kind of hard coded and so when
you're moving from from one server to
another you're moving to a bigger
instance or whatever you're doing that
really is a pretty manual process and we
migrate pings from one machine to
another but but it's a pretty manual
process and involves changing in fig
files on the short answer for so for the
general ping pool we we have a hash
which maps things to two servers and the
short answer is we don't change it a lot
I wish I had a had a fancier answer but
because of that issue where suddenly
everything needs to migrate servers we
or you know a large amount of data it
needs to migrate um it's just something
that happens really so the last time we
keep a lot of extra capacity around in
the last time that we that we migrated
was something like over over a year ago
um yeah one more can you tap into the
eye tracking software newer smartphones
to track whether visitors are actually
looking at a page um you know I hope
that we never never reach that level of
creepy older um yes so far we haven't I
mean you know I think to give a you know
a serious answer to me halfway jocular
question i think you know in the in
in reality when you're measuring stuff
on the internet there's only so accurate
you can be even with if you had some
fancy eye tracker it doesn't necessarily
know that the person is really actually
reading they might be just staring at
the page and so what what I i think you
know I use the phrase measurement
deliberately in the sense that you know
there's some real physical phenomenon
which is the person is looking at the
page and we have some mechanism which we
think measures some statistical property
which looks like a proxy for that
physical phenomenon it's not perfect
it's not going to be perfect no system
is going to be perfect and we we think
it's pretty good and we've done a lot of
experiments to kind of ensure the
fidelity of it but in the end it's it's
not going to be totally spot on the last
one I'm using this like a chat I blame
you haka I blame you thank you um all
right well with that let's let's jump
into the historical pipeline um so like
I said you know bolting on historical to
the back of a system that wasn't
engineered to be historical it can be an
interesting challenge um so let me talk
through a little bit of the evolution of
how we've done it um so the first kind
of v-0 of historical is something that
you you when you're looking at the
real-time dash you probably didn't even
think about being a historical number
but we have this graph which is showing
you know over time the state of the
real-time numbers right now memory fly
itself being an only real time system
only knows about the people who are on
the page right now right the second that
you close the page memory fly forgets
about you and never knows that you were
there right so memory fly can't answer
questions like draw me this graph right
on and so the the original charpy
basically only could give you numbers
about right now which was a neat product
but you know if you wanted to know okay
am i trending up over time it couldn't
answer questions like that so it's
pretty much immediately clear that we
needed to build something that could
give you some sort of historical data
and the simplest thing to do was to
basically take snapshots and so the
solution there was just on a 5-minute
cron we took a snapshot of every
aggregate that was inside of the Davis
right um it's a lot of aggregates um but
it's not that many address right so it's
it's on the order of you know
low terabytes per month because they're
these aggregate counts and not you know
every individual session um so let that
lets you do something like draw this
graph right so you can say okay well
what was that to you know this graph is
saying this point right here is the 2520
and you can ask okay what was that
number five minutes ago ten minutes ago
15 minutes ago 20 minutes ago and so on
and so that's a solution which works for
powering this product right um but the
second you try to actually do anything
cool on top of that you realize that
it's wholly inadequate to do almost
anything right because it's a system
that snapshot I'd metra it's sort of
pre-snap shouted metrics right and you
can try to add metrics to it but in the
end there's only so much that you can
add to be snapchatted and what you want
to be able to do is ask questions I
think the most interesting sort of
questions for us to ask when you're
analyzing traffic are not about you know
kind of the shape of pages over time but
rather rather the shape of users over
time right and and you to do that you
really need to be kind of you know
taking user by user pictures rather than
rather than sort of you know page by
page or site site by site pictures so so
we realized eventually that we really
needed to make a real kind of historical
data store that stored you know or
record for every session and so that's
kind of you know what maybe we'll call
v1 um so you know to go into
requirements again to make the system
work so we're going to have one record
for every single pageview that occurs so
that means that there are going to be
billions of records per day on it's also
in the spirit of what has worked well
for us in memory fly we also want a
system that can both answer ad hoc
queries so that we can do quick
development so that we can try out
building various models so that we can
look at numbers so that when a press
inquiry comes in we can pull some quick
stat for them and we also want to be
able to use the same system to actually
power production and so it both needs to
be low latency enough that you know it's
nice to use as a human and
high-throughput enough that it can
actually do useful things for for
production on
so to get into the actual setup of the
kind of data pipeline um this is this is
my simple state diagram which which is
basically ok so we're bolting something
onto the back of the real time system
and i'll talk about it something in a
minute um but there are these couple of
stages so first of all there's this
process that I'll call session ization
which is smashing together pings so
we've got a bunch of pings that all
represent data about a single pageview
and we want to end up with one record
not a thousand records if I stayed on
the page long enough to ping a thousand
times second of all we need to actually
transform it in some way that it can be
loaded into a data warehouse then we
load it into a data warehouse we use
Amazon redshift and I'll talk a little
bit about you know kind of why we chose
that and then we need to do some post
processing once it's loaded and I'll
talk about that in a bit and then of
course finally there's actually using
the whole thing later on but let's talk
about the pipeline first um so to jump
in with session ization so like I said
you know the issue is we've got a large
number of pings that each contain sort
of incremental data about a session so I
send a ping that says I've been on the
page 40 seconds I send a ping you know a
minute later that says I've been on the
page for a minute and you know and
people keep pages you know I probably
have 20 pages open on my computer right
now and for every one of those pages
that has chirpy running um they're
continually sending pings even during
the course this talk so so you end up
with a lot of pings per page you and oh
there's there's a lot of extraneous data
in there so the first thing that we want
to do is smash those together into one
record um we've tried a ton of
approaches for this on so to name a few
the first thing that we did is we
started with data and we capture data at
the ratting layer so essentially what
happened is is as the data comes into
engine acts and Gen X can dupe a ping to
another location so it sends it sends
the data into the memory fly at sending
it to and then engine X also dupes it to
a local process which writes the data to
disk that shipped to s3 and and goes on
its way but I but so there the data
that's being recorded is
ping by ping and then we did some sort
of offline process to session eyes those
to smash them together we've tried a
bunch of these the first thing that we
did that we knew wouldn't scale but we
thought a we might as well try it for
sort of our d is we just we did up certs
into a local database right so we were
running and we had a record per
user or paid for you and just as another
ping comes in it upsets itself into that
into that database anybody who's mess
around with knows immediately that
that will not work right uh uh um you
know it worked at small scale with with
you know thousands of records but if
you're gonna try to write hundreds of
thousands of records a second it's just
going to happen um so we started off
with that um we've tried a million other
approaches where we took these pings we
loaded them into sequel and tried to
smash them with sequel we try we've and
we're still doing a bunch of work on
pumping them through mr and smashing
them with EMR on and you know all of
these approaches sort of i think run
into the same problem which is that when
data is ordered on time it's actually
you know kind of a pain to do this right
I you know in the end you know you're
watching a person you start watching
them at some period of time and then two
hours later they send a ping and so in
order to smash their whole session
together you need to look at a huge
window of data and so you know if you're
if you imagine doing this in something
like EMR you just have to look at a very
large window of time in order to smash
things for a given period of time
together and that ends up just being
quite expensive in terms of moving data
around so another approach which we've
taken which has been really successful
is we realize like hey memory fly is
keeping track of these things and doing
this sessioning right so when a ping
comes in like i mentioned a memory fly
says you know okay was this ping was
this session already seen if so update
my my record for that session if not
then create a new session and then
eventually memory fly when it thinks
you're not on the page anymore it
deletes you out and goes on its merry
way so the thing that we we realized is
well when memory fly is deleting you out
it doesn't just have to delete you
and decrement you from your accounts it
also can write you to disk and chip that
test three right um and adding that
adding that step to the to the process I
think it was was pretty huge in terms of
simplifying stuff so I think maybe the
the lesson there is you know if you've
already got some things fifth listening
on this chain of you you may as well use
it um and and doing that smashing in
that stage just helps immeasurably in
terms of in terms of data processing um
so and just a note in there this is just
an example of what I mentioned earlier
so every ping sort of ships with this
timer so this ping says you know if you
don't hear from me it has a 45 in this
record which says if you don't hear from
me in 45 seconds consider me gone things
have a depending on how frequently
they're being sent that parameter
changes but basically every pings and
ships with something that says you can
delete me after this kind of a TTL and
so we take advantage of that to do the
session 8 on so from there um we have an
ETL process it's not the most exciting
thing I don't know if it could be so
basically we have to do three things we
have to transform it to CSV redshift
read CSV so you just have to you know
take what was just a URL and you know
from an image request turn it into a CSV
we have to do a bunch of valid
validation sanitization so you know it's
the internet sometimes URLs come in male
form sometimes they have incoherent
values you want to avoid losing as much
data as you possibly can so you recover
what you can you know if a field is
non-essential and malformed you just you
know empty it out and if something is
really male formed in a way that it
can't be loaded into the database then
you drop it and finally we attach a
bunch of new metadata so maybe the two
interesting examples are we do a bunch
of user agent classification um so you
know you might when a ping comes in and
has it has a you a string which tells
you what sort of browser it came from so
the two important things are one sort of
obviously on the traffic side we care
about classifying desktop traffic versus
mobile traffic versus tablet traffic you
know windows versus iOS all that sort of
stuff so that happen
I based on the UA and and then the other
thing that we do is we flag things as
whether or not they're coming from from
bots or from from things that look human
of course that doesn't get you every bot
but some things like Google bot want to
be found right so they come in with a UA
that identifies himself as that and it
did you know makes a measurable
difference on on traffic so all of that
stuff happens in the in the transform
stage then that data is loaded up into
redshift to walk you through for a
second what redshift sort of buys you
it's uh it's basically just a big amazon
managed postgres system it doesn't do
everything that postgres does it does a
little bit of stuff that post Coast
doesn't do but uh but it pretty much is
just sequel which I didn't think I would
ever spend my time writing and then I
spend a lot of time writing but I but
yeah so it speaks sequel you know it's
fast it scales well you can resize
clusters all that it's column-oriented
so you know it handles aggregations well
and it handles compression really well
importantly for us it does batch imports
from s3 well and quickly and so we can
import you know it essentially you know
scales to any amount of data that we've
wanted to throw in it and that that
that's really been it's essential
property we experimented with a ton of
different databases trying to see why
what would be the right thing you know
we tried things like Cassandra redshift
just did what we wanted better on so to
talk through you know I think this is
probably fairly specific to to red shift
so I don't wanna spend a ton of time on
it but we've learned some important
lessons which I imagine some people in
this room are going to use it so some
things that are important that we've
that we have come out of redshift so
first of all joins are the worst in in
sequel and and especially in red shift
and you basically you know if you want
something to be performance you can't
use them right and so I the price of
that is duplicating data so you know i
have three examples we're basically a
ping you know there are three let's say
you have fields that you have to be
normalized or you'd have to store in
some start structure
and we'd be normalize in every possible
case so that so that we can avoid
joining um i don't i don't think i can
give a clock on what the speed up for
that was but it's of the order of you
know we felt like we couldn't use red
shift and then when we started d
normalizing tables we felt like we could
use red shift so it's kind of a kind of
a game changer in that sense I'm second
of all you know sometimes you have
things where you have to join you have
infrequent queries that you run that
just needed to be joined um and the
important thing here which is a fairly
recent thing that I think we've really I
come to understand is it so there's this
notion of the distribution key which is
basically you know your your your data
is charted across a number of what they
call slices which are essentially a disk
with the CPU attached to it and and a
distribution key decides for each row
which slice it lives on and you can you
apply a distribution key to each table
so if you apply the same distribution
key to two tables it guarantees that any
two things that have the same key you
know key are going to end up on the same
disk and if you're joining and you can
avoid network it's a huge win so I
changing our table structure so that we
used the most common kia we joined on as
our distribution key gave us something
like a 5x speed up on joins and a 10x
speed up on grouping on it on that key
which is obviously a huge one on the
final note is there's also this
parameter called a sort key which
decides you know given all of the data
that's lying on a specific disk for a
specific table how is it physically
sorted on disk and again on you know you
get huge speed ups from sort of using
this correctly so almost all of our
queries as you might imagine our kind of
windowed on time so we're asking you
know how many ex has happened yesterday
how many ex has happened over the last
month and because of that you know if
you're sorting the data on disk in terms
of time you just avoid having a look at
you know 99 percent of the data and you
get pretty much a linear speed-up in
terms of that so if you're looking at
half the data it runs twice as fast a
tenth of their runs sometimes as fast
and so we found you know somewhere
depending on the range of the data
somewhere between a 10
2x speed up between the two um so in
combination you know we're talking about
between those three insights getting i
would say three orders of magnitude of
speed up on which you know obviously 300
magnitude is great i but but i think you
know really like i can't stress enough
if you use it how much you need to do
this right we went from a system that
was you know essentially didn't work
right that were where we just said when
we first loaded loaded data up in into
this cluster we felt like we didn't get
anything out of it all and now it's able
to power you know tens of thousands of
queries running nightly against it bet
you know multiple data scientists and
engineers and beckon engineers running
queries against it I you know throughout
the day and it's able to keep up so yeah
it's been great but only with a lot of a
lot of unpleasantness in the meantime um
so finally one other thing that I think
is kind of an interesting lesson on top
of this is is is our post import
processing so there's some stuff that
you need to do if you're going to take
in traffic data on to things that are
really important that I'm giving us
examples of this all right you need to
deduplicate and you need to do some
fancy robot detection so do duplicating
you know try as you might you're going
to end up with you know for some reason
somebody's pinging and then four hours
later some phantom pain comes in for the
same session and your session ization
was insufficient to get it right um
we've done a lot of work at trying to
push this to the session ization side so
messing around with with what we could
do on the on the you know ingestion side
to get rid of duplicates but no matter
what we did we basically were ending up
with something but depending on the
domain between five and ten percent
duplicate rows which is totally
unacceptable if you're giving people
accurate numbers especially we do a lot
of stuff tracking ads and with ads since
it's directly attached to commerce you
have to be right and i and and so you
need to deduplicate and eventually we
sort of realized well d duplicating on
the on the session ization side is quite
hard but d duplicating in sequel is just
this query right it's really easy and it
runs in a couple of seconds for even a
very large table
so I so we sort of you know switch
switch to that and and it basically
allowed us to simplify our our
socialization an ETL process quite a bit
another example of that is this graph on
the right with new axes on it which it
which is is basically I like I said we
need to do some some fancy robot
detection so we detect robotic pings
from looking at their user agent but you
can imagine that there's web traffic out
there that doesn't want you to know that
its robotic but is and there's a whole
world of people out there whose whole
job it is to detect traffic like this I
won't claim that we are as good as they
at it but we do as best we can and so
you know what this graph is showing us
is just one example of how we do this so
this is kind of in an overly fancy way
basically taking a Fourier transform of
how frequently people are visiting the
pages and looking for spikes so you know
we can see for instance this thing is is
for a given period we're seeing as you'd
expect these lines to be flat if there
were no kind of periodic page and visit
periodic pattern and visiting pages
these funny spiky things are things that
are oddly regular visits to a site and
so if you see something like that you
might suspect that it's a robotic user
or something running on a cron or
whatever it is and you might want to
flag that as suspicious and hold it out
and again I doing that on the ingestion
side I have no idea really how you would
accomplish it right because you need to
be able to look at historical data and
we thought about you know okay do we
somehow you know keep some lookup table
which is storing suspicious stuff and
then as pings come in you look them up
in the lookup table that just seems
really complicated when you're talking
about you know billions and billions of
records um but again you know generating
this sort of stuff you know on the
sequel site is actually quite easy and
so you know pulling it to doing one
sequel query I ended up being a big win
over trying to trying to make a very
complicated detail pipeline um so I
think that's all I've got on the ETL
side on with the the time I've got left
I wanted to talk about you know one
kind of neat application of this reason
this actually before I do that any
question okay so I think you just
handled a bad data one right someone
asks have you ever had someone attack
memory fly with fake data uh no not at
least not that we know of so so we do
the best job that we can to detect um as
far as you we've had bad actors but not
in the sense of attackers we've had bad
actors like you know a site that does
something crazy you know puts five
fingers on a page that are all pinging
us at once or something like that but
what we haven't had to handle truly
malicious people how do you decide on a
TTL for a session great question so it's
basically I so things I which is
determined by the you know mostly what
we care about when we're measuring time
they're spending so if you're sitting on
the nine percent of people are doing on
any given web page you don't really have
to do anything and so if a person's idle
we send very infrequent pings if a
person is making activity we send much
more frequent things so the TTL is just
a formula on top of that so it's some
multiple of you know the ping frequency
plus a little bit of a constant in case
something gets hung up it basically lets
us drop one ping and then have there be
a little bit of jitter in the network
memory flies seems to have evolved
evolved in a pre Redis world if you
could do it over now how do you feel
about Redis um you know I guess I
personally don't have enough experience
with Redis to have a substantially
informed opinion but I will say that you
know I think like most architectures I
we would not have done it the same way
if we were doing it now um it was there
was no great in-memory data store five
and a half years ago and so it was
rolled by hand and yeah it probably
wouldn't be in a world where you have
red s in a world where you could be
doing a lot of this stuff in something
like storm we probably would have done
it and that
that stuff we're sort of actively
researching whether or not we should be
we should be thinking about about
pipelines like that and this is a
specific question on the etl stuff how
do you see Vertica and bigquery compared
to read redshift to query billions of
Records a great question you know I I
haven't I think vertica is is vertical
we haven't touched bigquery i think is
interesting um so I guess I don't you
know I don't have an extremely informed
opinion I think they're all interesting
they're all you know you might I guess I
would I there's no point in speculating
based on on conversations that that I've
had with folks but you might get better
performance out of them I think that you
know for us the performance that we've
gotten out of redshift has been
sufficient and in order to get a to have
redshift do a different thing for us
we'd probably need another two orders of
magnitude reduction in speed which I
don't imagine anything would give us so
I to me the kind of phase change would
happen and this is something we'll talk
about on the reporting side right now
are our use of redshift for powering
production is basically you know it's
built around the fact that redshift
queries are fast but not quite fast
enough to really power a dashboard so
you have queries that might take half a
second you have queries that might take
20 seconds you have big queries that
might take five minutes um and I and we
don't even want to make people wait five
seconds okay and so what we do is
basically in every case that we can much
like those memory fly precomputed counts
in every case that we can we at night
enumerate all queries that we definitely
know we want the results of run them and
cash the results and serve the results
out of cash um if Richard for tours of
magnitude faster we might be able to
query it directly from the dash um it's
not designed to do that it has
concurrency limits no not so I don't
know that we would anyway but but you
know if it were 5x faster it would be
great but it wouldn't wouldn't change
what it can do
alright um so yeah let me not you know
take the last couple minutes to talk
about some some historical reporting
stuff that we're doing so I one of the
coolest things I think yeah you know has
come out of my team in the last few
months is uh is this stuff that
basically takes a bunch of you know all
of this quantitative data that's in red
shift and spits out these actual human
readable reports which you all sitting
back there probably can't read a word of
but trust me they're really cool uh and
so so basically the idea is is so this
is part of a product that we have for
advertising the basic use case of this
thing is there are you know people in
the world whose job it is to go out and
say you should advertise on you know
chirpy calm because our site is so good
these are the following cool things
about it people on social media love us
whatever whatever right and those people
you know often are really sort of
talking on gut right so you know you're
saying well you know what you know
charpy traffic would be like it's the
best right people are so smart and so
high income and whatever right um but
the interesting thing is that because
we're really measuring you know
everything about how people are
consuming the site we can spit out some
pretty interesting insights about how
people consume and sort of play those
back to a person who can then talk about
the site so what this thing is doing is
actually spitting out you know
paragraphs of text that that we think
are good ways to describe the site along
with a bunch of sort of supporting facts
so for folks who can't read this
sentence says when it comes to the
amount of time people spend reading
content you know XCOM generally
outperforms the internet or reader spend
59 seconds per article which is more
than 3x or competition your campaign
we're talking about in the ad campaign
ran equally across the site and was
therefore able to take advantage of all
of our content blah blah blah right on
and then we have a bunch you know we
have the supporting facts so for example
people from facebook.com spent 55
thousand seven hundred and thirty-seven
seconds looking at ads from this
campaign right um so there are these
sorts of features that are fitters that
are spit out as well so i'm going to
talk through
how this stuff gets generated it's
probably less cool than you think it is
although it's still pretty cool so uh so
first of all is I wanted to make a quick
point which I made earlier but it's this
notion that with you know all of this
stuff is kind of run offline we
precompute what we can we so we have a
sink workers they cash the result in
those the Magos are what are
actually serving our api's to the dash
so that's the sort of architecture of
everything that I'm going to talk about
um so in general the first approach that
we tried is basically you enumerate a
bunch of things that might be
interesting to say about a site right
maybe the site has great traffic from
some refer maybe a site you know has
terrible traffic versus the internet you
a new right you know a ton of things
that might be true and you numerate them
in a way that that we call like a mad
lib right so you know my example here
that simple is X of your top stories
received significant traffic from social
sources right okay so that's a mad lib a
human wrote that sentence right um so
you write that sentence down and then so
that's some fact and we'll call that
fact foo right then you write two other
things first of all you write you write
a function which fills in the madlib
will call that the data function right
and so that's a function where ok so
this sentence is x of our top stories
received social traffic we need to
actually grab the X right so you write
something which given access to some set
of data can compute that X right then
you write what I'm calling a relevance
function which is some you know a
detector that decides whether or not foo
would be a smart thing to say right so
for example if zero of your top stories
received traffic from social stories you
probably don't want to say that as the
intro to you know to your story about
your site right if 10 of them did then
it's probably good right um and so so
you can kind of you know enumerate a ton
of thing of things of these form where
you have a sentence a data function or
relevance function and then basically
run through them and so in v1 of this
process what we did is basically i
enumerate a ton of them and then just
run them all right so start with the
first one run it run its relevance
function
if relevance function says true run data
function if you know throw data function
into the sentence story right and run
them all right now of course that's
extraordinarily inefficient you know if
you have a thousand sentences you have
to run a thousand relevance functions
and maybe a thousand data functions that
gets expensive um it's also you know if
you're sort of doing that it's pretty
hard to share you know what might be
shared stay between between the
relevance functions you can cash but
beyond that you know it's you don't have
any coherent state that also sort of
trickles down to tell what sort of
narratives you spit out so so doing an
architecture like that you can kind of
spit out sentences like this so these
sentences on the right this campaign was
featured in the opinion section right
you can spit out a sentence like that
you can't spit out a paragraph like we
have on the left because you don't
really detect any structure between
between the queries right um so for both
of those reasons we decided to go down
this this complicated route of something
that's a little bit better which is
basically I'm structuring structuring
facts into a decision tree and then kind
of walking the decision tree so this is
just an example of a tree that you might
use and we apply a number of trees and
sort of walk all the things that are
relevant so the example here is okay so
if we're trying to decide what you know
smart things to say say about a site the
first question you might ask in this
sort of structure is say okay does the
site actually have high engagement
compared to other sites on the Internet
if no we're not going to talk about you
know anything related to engagement
we're going to talk about other things
right if yes we'll say something about
whether the site has high engagement and
then we you know we ask a series of
questions trying to trying to define you
know which kind of branches to search on
right on that search then kind of
inherently implies the paragraph
structure right so you can actually
think you can imagine you know walking
this tree and seeing the result so here
if we say you know according to this red
line this is a site that has high
engagement for the Internet this was a
targeted can't this was a nut a non
targeted campaign it was saturated
across the
across the site so you might write a
sentence that says your site is super
engaging and although this campaign
wasn't targeted it reached almost
everybody in your audience right and so
so walking the tree implies a narrative
structure which you can sort of by
filling in the mad libs along each way
you can end up with with with the
coherent sentence then when you reach
the bottom you have some pool of fact
which you can compute results on and
then and then kind of fill fill those in
to end up with with all this takeaways
to the right you can run this for a
bunch of trees and and end up with with
a bunch of stories that are that are all
kind of you know nicely structured on so
I think with that that's pretty much
what i've got let me run through a
little bit of a future work and then to
take some final questions but um so in
terms of stuff that we definitely you
know are actively exploring amongst a
million other things so first of all i'm
a lot of the counting that were you know
what i'd like to do is move our use of
things like red shift to be as
sophisticated as possible and not use
regice for stuff that we don't have to
use it for can only handle so many
queries and stuff that doesn't need to
hit it shouldn't right so something like
those fancy robot detection things
really does need red shift because you
need to be able to do queries that are
across time in complicated ways but
something like you know counting how
many you know pageviews a individual
article has gotten across the last month
does not need anything historical right
you can listen on the stream and do that
count um you know with you know
probabilistic data structures like hyper
logs and count sketches you can count
you know pretty accurately things like
you know unique visitors or frequency
and things like that and so something
that i'd like to do is move all of our
you know straight up counting out of
redshift whenever possible and and move
it to just counting directly on the
stream another thing which i'll use as a
plug for CTOs talk this weekend at pi
Gotham is the use of foreign data
wrappers which are pretty much the
coolest thing a foreign data wrapper
in a sentence is something which
basically allows postgres to interface
with some data store whatever it is
right so you write you know in our case
most of our code bases in Python so you
write up Python function which just
supplies an interface to postgres and so
for instance I you know you could have
let's say you know we have a tan
spitball an example we have something
like data coming in from from Gannett
that's just raw tweets and we don't want
to load them into redshift but we want
redshift to be able to talk to that to
that data store anyway by sort of
wrapping that that stream inside of a
foreign data rapper you can put queries
against it they're really fun and pretty
easy to use another thing which I want
to do is sort of take that language
generation stuff stuff one level deeper
so right now we're sort of parsing facts
into trees and then using trees to you
know to sort of project back down into
paragraphs instead what I'd like to do
is really start with lower level fact so
you can imagine little kind of atomic
facts like just a single number or a
single you know pick up of a referrer
onto something and sort of parsing those
into sentences and just basically doing
doing one one more level on top of that
which I think you know one of the
interesting challenges is that with any
sort of automatically generated text you
you need as much variety as possible
it's getting as close to the data as
possible I think there's just a lot of
writing and data so getting down there
might might get us to that um so with
that I should say that you know we're
pretty much always hiring you should go
to turf ecomme slash jobs or email me or
whatever and yeah thanks for your
listening and love to your questions
alright last chance to get your
questions in if you missed the site
before it's a che kk a labs dot co all
right so here's one that we didn't ask
before can custom queries be done by
users or only by chart beat developers
if so how do you sandbox C++ code to
avoid users reading info from other
people's domains oh great question um so
in general most custom queries can only
be done by charpy but there is some so I
guess there are kind of two versions of
custom queries so there there are parts
of the dashboard which are not
implemented in this in this c++ code
which require sort of that lua interface
to get the results then you have true
custom queries true custom queries on
the real time are only runnable by
tripping employees um it still raises an
interesting question which is we'd like
to be able to write our own custom
queries and be in a sandbox environment
so that we don't let's say write a query
which takes so long that it breaks the
actual production memory fly um we have
a dev environment but sometimes you
actually need production traffic and so
so there's actually a really nice kind
of wrap around this where you get when
you're right running the lua code you
get this sandbox environment so for
instance if you're Lua co-manages to
segfault itself it doesn't crash memory
fly it just crashes itself so it really
is an isolated environment um and as far
as different hosts the different house
are really segmented on two different
processes so you don't have to worry so
much about sort of security concerns
it's more about performance concerns we
have how long do you keep full
resolution of data do you batch
aggregate roll-ups on some rolling frame
seven days one minute resolution for
eight to thirty days our resolution for
one month plus we keep full resolution
data forever right now hi yeah chance me
cool anyone else last chance yeah into
our user ID a good question so our user
ID is stored on a first-party cookie
which means that it doesn't track people
between sites it's only tracking people
on a specific site
um there's actually a really interesting
I it we could probably spend a whole
talk on it um there's a funny problem
which is that so for reasons that are
probably mostly legacy reasons we
generate the user ID on the client side
it's not a uuid which is surf from the
server on there's an interesting problem
which is that uh you know when this code
was first written you know chirpy was a
small company and so the way that the
user ID was generated was 16 consecutive
calls to rand on and the problem with
that is that if you don't have a lot of
entropy in the browser you end up with
not that much interview and user ID and
the entropy and your user ID basically
is something like 32 bits if you're on a
32-bit system right now you end up with
collision so if you're if you're trying
to hash you know if you have 32 bits of
hash space and you're trying to and
you're trying to hat sorry if you have
something like 64 bits of hash space and
you're trying to handle hash 32 bits of
things to to the 32 things you start
being worried about collisions so I with
32 bits of entropy we could only handle
two to the sixth yeah yeah Marie yeah to
the 60 no I'm backwards to the 16 things
without being worried about collisions
which is not a lot of things right is so
we had to we basically had to get very
worried about collisions and what we end
up doing is just juicing every possible
piece of entropy we can get so we rather
than making calls to R and we make a
call to ran we look at the width of the
browser the height of the browser the
path the person is on the you know if we
can get access to what extensions are
installed you know every possible thing
that we do to just make a big string
that has as much entropy as possible in
it our back of the envelope is that that
thing has something like eighty four
bits of entropy which means that we can
handle around two to the 42 things
without collisions which is not that
many I mean that's a lot it's for user
IDs it's enough there are not two to the
42 users right but for sessions there
might be two to the 42 sessions and we
have
sessionid also so it's kind of pushing
it it's the best that we can do on the
client side but you know the number of
collisions is as far as we know so it's
doing that completely solved a user user
ID collision thing and also solve the
session anything but it's it's like a
back of the mind concern for later
thanks Josh so we have a bunch of
interesting meetups coming up as soon as
everybody gets back from your summer
labor day break talk to us if your if
your company wants to present something
interesting this was an awesome talk if
you have something equally awesome or
even slightly less awesome we might
consider it this is a high bar but find
me or Julia are one of the haka folks in
the back thanks for coming